so tamanna me now it starts off fairly
gentle even though you're like what I've
delivered both ways okay so you're
normally thinking of graph up here right
so first I have flipped vertically it
goes on to underneath the x-axis and
secondly I flipped horizontally so
that's why it is getting closer to 0
rather than racing away from 0 okay so
there's my general shape I have my
horizontal asymptote there it's got to
be labeled and I have my quick for scale
way on over here okay because it's a to
the power it's the base is 3 that's why
I've got three over there you've got
your domain stated and there's your
range of course because it has to be
negative and it never touches the axis
so that's why it's not inclusive of the
battery all right this was an easy one
maybe I should put this on first anyhow
you needed the intercepts on there
please make sure that the person you're
marking has the intersect and of course
all your values of x or we're values of
Y all right now here's the here's the
square root function okay now because
it's full minus X okay that means min to
that means that even though normal
square root looks like this right okay
because there's a minus on the X it's
being flipped horizontally that's why
mine is facing the other way okay
because there's a 4 it's been moved over
to the right okay it's been shrinking
because it's a 4 minus X which is really
actually minus of X minus 4 that's a bit
weird remember we talked about this the
minus actually placed that whole thing
and minus 4 means to the right four
units of course you could just put in x
equals 4 & Co okay it works and so
that's that's where it ends you should
have a filled circle right there and so
there's your domain xicot to be less
than or equal four and you're a company
range okay and then we've got the field
you can see I messed up mine on my own
so there's my high public it's been
shifted horizontally and vertically it's
been shifted horizontally extreme units
to the left which you can see from that
plus two and
shifted four units upwards which you can
see from the minus 40 even though that's
a bit of a mess having those two shifts
and therefore those two asymptotes the
nice thing about it is because it gives
you two intercepts so you don't need
points for scale because your intercepts
function as your points the scale okay
so you've got your domain there excuse
me thank you and hum as I said this is
the way that I like to state it sometime
you can see how about X minus 1 so I've
been shifted one unit to the right sorry
that's Big O one get it to the right so
there's my new asymptote rather x equals
0 which is my normal isotope so it's
moved over that means i have a new
intercept because my intercept is
usually one it's been moved over to the
right so now it's too now the trickiest
part is to work out a point for scale
because you should have a point for
scale of this one okay this point here
it's a bit hard to ribbons t plus 1 the
reason why I've chosen a plus one is
because what i want is a nice easy
number right so if i do log face even if
you don't know what he actually is if i
put in IE + 1 in there oops sorry don't
in the bracket and minus 1 because
that's what the function says okay
that's going to give me log base a of e
very good which of course is just all
sorry that should be on that should be
one okay so that gives you like it's
it's about as close as you can get to a
nice convenient value so you could have
put in a decimal head you know it would
have been okay to be honest but that's
that's a precise way of doing it okay
all right as we got his absolute i'm
sorry i forgot the domain range so x is
greater than one from the never touch of
the asymptote and of course why can't go
anywhere it pleases absolute value it
was a nice simple absolute value it's
been shifted to the right four units
because you can see if X points4 and you
can see there for you've got all your
values of x as usual y can be equal to 0
because of course if x is equal to four
you are actually at that point so
there's no discontinuity or anything
like that okay so now we have the
semicircle we talked about very briefly
the forms of the equations of semi
circles you can see it's y equals so she
that- that- is really on the wine which
is why I've got the bottom half of the
city so
from 60 minus x squared if you want to
think about it in a crude way let's do
it here if I square both sides i get
this you see that that would be squaring
both sides of course once you do square
both sides that means now you've got
both halves of the semicircles you know
both positive social so you don't really
want that but it gives you an idea of
the shape because once you move the x
squared over the other side you see it's
a familiar circle with Center origin and
radius for Frank so once you remember
that that's how you get your inter stats
and you just want the bottle part you
should have filled circles at the ends
because you can be equal to x equals 4
and negative 4 because taking the square
root of zero is fine and lastly the cube
root of x this is a tricky one we
haven't really looked at it and even
mine is not particularly impressive ok
but you can see if the hay is very very
much like the square root of x in terms
of like it's growing but it slows down
it slows down it slows down the
difference of course is why you can't
take the square root of a negative
number you can't take a cube root like
the cube root of negative 8 is negative
2 because if you do negative 2 times
negative 2 times negative 2 sure enough
you get negative 8 so the cube roots of
negative numbers exist by the way it
just as a bonus right it's a cube root
right cute so it's like a three what
kind of symmetry does this puncture have
it has odd symmetry because it's just
like the cubic function in fact it's
what we call the inverse will get in
fact into detail later so you've got
this shape not that you should I
wouldn't mark it down because I haven't
gone through formally but just for the
sake of it see this y-axis right the
cube root function should actually be
tangent to the y-axis see how I'm
actually flat there like it's not it's
not going to pass through like the side
and the X curves you know how they do
this so you can see it's not vertical
there but the cube root function it is
vertically don't worry we'll get into
all the details of that later but just
so that you can note that for future ok
so I wouldn't mock neck down but it is
correct